you
good morning Henry well I guess good
afternoon
you probably slept like a rock anyway
there's still a few hours of daylight to
get some work in I can see you at your
desk so call me when you're ready
Hey
sorry guess I slept in you got a
relaxing what 14 hours of sleep oh yeah
Jesus I guess it's what 6:00 6:45 whoops
don't worry about it that hike puts
everyone out of commission for a day or
two but now that you're up
let me quickly get you acquainted with
the job there's a thing in the middle of
your room with a round map on it do you
see it okay yeah I see it this is the
Osborne fire finder invented in 1914 by
WB Osborne you use this to spot you
guessed it fine
what the [ __ ] what is it nothing you use
this to [ __ ] me it got language lady out
your west facing window are you seeing
what I've seen those [ __ ] fireworks I
need you to confirm do you see them whoa
that's not legal right ah no you need to
get down there right now and stop them
fire dangerous through the [ __ ] roof
is that really my job your job is
whatever I say it is Luke the closest
Ranger is like two days away go down
there and set him straight
do I write him a ticket easy there Dirty
Harry well get going you'll probably
need a rope to get down the shale
between you and the lake if I remember
right there should be one in the supply
box on the way the code is one two three
four it's actually that for all of them
secure shut up
I take it you fell prey to the Forest
Service's big recruiting effort when it
comes to you know how the hell you ended
up out here
I saw the job in the paper and figured
you know what the heck what the heck
I've got no ties and no life better go
spend what's left of it in utter
loneliness something like that yeah
thanks to last summer the bump in Forest
Service budget actually allowed for us
to advertise for the job glad it worked
this shale slide is steep how do you
expect me to get down this I don't
remember it being that bad it's not even
named on our toe pose
what about shitty boss is gonna get me
killed he'll Oh is that it's Orca Indian
maybe maybe Creek that's actually
English for not in my job description
hey my shitty boss almost got me killed
first your boss is a delight secondly
Jesus what exactly happened
my rope snapped coming down the shale
slide you didn't break anything did you
no I think I'll make it I'll be careful
for Christ's sake
um there's a critter out here
I found it brah we're now we're the
idiots were shooting fireworks I think
they're naked
found them in the lake naked I know you
guys are setting up bottle rockets out
here okay Lily he probably hasn't seen
boobs in 20 years what are you throwing
stuff at us what was that your [ __ ]
fireworks also setting off fireworks out
here isn't just stupid it's illegal
oh hey
[ __ ] cool it with the fireworks
and I go okay
we'll find music oh sorry
I took their stereo okay well I can
swear I'll even then ya think so but
seriously though thanks for dealing with
it
so I have a bit of a confession to make
ah what's in this cave down here in
Thunder Canyon Thunder Canyon hey I
didn't name it but in the cave rocks not
to go too far in there it's pretty
dangerous so so I say [ __ ] it man you
can go where you want great
you used to go caving with someone back
in Colorado she loved it might be great
to explore it sometime the summer that
could be fun obviously be very careful
there's some guy out here giving me the
creeps creeps
wait he's looking at you is he doing
anything else like I don't think so
Henry there's there's something I
something someone should have told you
about this area what is it it's outside
come on the whole thing and people come
and go as they please it's it's it's
madness yeah yeah okay I get it
[ __ ] bumping into someone in the middle
of nowhere is part of the fun
Oh
what can I do for you well my typewriter
is on the ground outside of my tower you
right yeah look the wind no how the hell
you should get inside [ __ ] me
someone broke in people edge it just
they wrecked the place through my
typewriter out the window [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] what the Forest Service no
what happened
my [ __ ] sheets are gone they stole
your sheet that's just me yeah it sucks
the place is trashed
believe this [ __ ] then I have to fix the
window tomorrow that was fast
yeah well do you have any idea who could
have done this I did probably piss off
the girls at the lake [ __ ] them I'll
have the Rangers keep an eye out for a
couple of young women and question any
they find I can't believe someone would
do this I worry about bears and fires
and that's about it and now I've got to
worry about some deranged hiker going
after lookouts great not a great first
day for me no it's not I hope you didn't
drag a black cloud out here with you
okay
in the morning I'm gonna call my friend
Patti who works the desk down in Cody
they keep a list of everyone who's
officially been in and out of the
trailhead since I don't know forever and
see if we can get a list of names get
much but at least if anything else
happens we can refer to it and see if
anything comes up Thanks
I need you to feel safe out here just
point me to the Forest Service weapons
cache and I'll feel safer than the Pope
in his little car yeah someone made the
choice years ago that leaving people
with infinite amounts of alone time and
a gun
kind of a bad idea grenades I'll see
what I can do
you